hello everybody and welcome to another
python 3 basics video in this video
we're going to be discussing the basics
of a python function
the idea of a function is to assign a
set of code and possibly variables known
as parameters to a single bit of text so
you can think of it a lot like why you
choose to write and save a program
rather than writing out the entire
program every time you want to execute
it or in a much smaller scale why we use
variables
so to begin a function you define the
function
by using the keyword def def short for
defined
and this notifies python of the
impending function definition
from there you're going to type out
whatever name you want to refer to your
function as now you want to be kind of
careful in the name of your function
just like you would want to be careful
in the name of your variable you want to
choose something unique and it's not
going to
conflict with anything else like
time you know if you define a function
and you called it time it's going to
conflict with the time module should you
use it so you don't want to use time so
for us we're just going to use example
and after the definition of the
function's name you have uh the
parentheses and within the parenthesis
you have any parameters if you have any
parameters that is
uh for now we're just going to leave
those empty but i will show you guys in
some future videos
how to use parameters
after the parenthesis you have a colon
and then you hit enter and basically
everything you type under here is going
to be your function block so as you type
code and you hit enter you've got this
is all contained in your function and
then finally when you come over here and
start typing more code that's outside of
the function so this is the function so
that's kind of the idea of python
standards
whereas other programming languages
generally you're going to have
curly braces and you type within the
curly braces and blah blah
we use just indent and indent only
so for example we're just going to say
print
basic function
and then we'll actually you know call
over or assign a variable that's going
to be 3 plus 9 and we'll even print that
variable out when we call this function
and that's basically it
now if we go to run this program you'll
find that nothing happens so we hit run
and nothing happens now sometimes just
like trips people up and what's happened
is we've defined the function but we've
not actually
uh called the function into action so to
do that you can either type it out so
example empty parameters hit enter and
it says basic function 12.
another thing that you can do is
literally within your script you can
type out example and when you go to run
it it will just automatically run so you
don't have to actually type it in
yourself
so this is the function basics
in the next video we're going to be
talking about is parameters in the
functions because parameters uh add
quite a bit of uh
dynamic variability to your function so
that's what we're gonna be talking about
in the next video stay tuned for that as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time